en este vídeo resolveremos un par de
ecuaciones a manera de calentamiento las
cuales para resolverlas requieren más
pasos de los que hemos hecho en vídeos
previos posteriormente resolveremos un
problema de aplicación donde pondremos a
prueba nuestras habilidades para
resolver ecuaciones aquí tenemos 7 por w
20 - w es igual a 5 veamos cómo
resolverla y como en todas las
ecuaciones hay muchas maneras de
resolverlas yo haré la que me parece más
natural para empezar puede distribuir
los números así distribuyendo el 7
obtendré 7 w a lo cual le podría restar
w y así tener las dobles juntas de
alguna manera entonces aplicando la
propia distributiva 7 por doble u más 20
es igual a 7 por w más 7 por 20 más 140
estamos aplicando la propiedad
distributiva ya eso le restamos w menos
w lo cual es igual a 5 únicamente
reescribir esto distribuye el 7 y ahora
ya podemos juntar las dobles aquí
tenemos 7 w
- w
es siete volúmenes dobles seis doble
acuérdate si tienes siete de algo y las
restas uno de algo te da seis de sial 6w
más 140 y eso es igual a
ahora quiero deshacerme de este 140 del
lado izquierdo para dejar 6 w y así
dividiendo entre 6 se obtendría la
solución de la ecuación para deshacerme
de 140 voy a restar 140 a ambos lados de
la ecuación
entonces restamos 140 del lado izquierdo
aquí hay que ponerle el signo más
140 del lado derecho si un algo es igual
a otro algo un algo menos 140 va a ser
igual al otro algo menos 140 en una
ecuación lo que hagas de un lado lo
tienes que hacer del otro lado el
objetivo de este paso fue cancelar estos
140 y nos queda del lado izquierdo 6w y
de la derecha nos queda 5 menos 140 y
eso es igual a menos 135 ahora dividimos
ambos lados entre 6 que es lo mismo que
multiplicar por un sexto ambos lados y
del lado izquierdo que nos queda 6 entre
6 es 1 nos queda w y del lado derecho
nos queda menos 135 sextos y esto ya no
se puede simplificar más veamos esto no
es divisible entre 2
tampoco es divisible entre 3
así es que parece ser que ya hemos
resuelto
la ecuación y esta solución es algo que
tú podrías comprobar de hecho vamos a
comprobarlo pues este número me parece
un poco extraño entonces sustituyendo en
la ecuación original es 7 por w que es
menos 135 sobre 6 y eso más 20 pero a
poner el 20 como 120 sextos 20 es lo
mismo que 120 sextos ya eso le vamos a
restar w que es menos
menos
sextos y aquí tenemos menos por menos
esto es más así es que esto es más 135
sextos y ahora tenemos
7 x menos 135 sextos más 120 sextos y
esto es igual a menos 15 sextos 7 x
menos 15 sextos más 135 sextos veamos
que obtenemos aquí tenemos 7 x menos 15
sextos 7 x menos 15 sextos vamos a
hacerlo por acá 7 x menos 15 es 7 por 10
70 7 por 5 35 esto sería menos
105 sextos esto corresponde a esta
cantidad de aquí ya eso le sumamos
135 sextos que es este término que
tenemos aquí menos 105 sextos más 135
sextos es igual a 30 sextos que es igual
a 55 a lo que necesitábamos que fuera
así es que estamos bien esta es la
solución me parece un número un poco
raro pero no hicimos las cosas
adecuadamente resolvamos ahora esta
ecuación distribuyamos primeramente el 9
como hemos dicho hay varias maneras de
hacer esto posteriormente veremos otra
manera por lo pronto distribuimos el 9
para no tener que hacer operaciones con
fracciones entonces distribuyendo el 9
que obtenemos 9 x menos 18 es igual a 3
x + 3
vamos a agruparlas x del lado izquierdo
para eso necesitamos restar 3 x del lado
derecho
menos 3 x del lado derecho y menos 3 x
del lado izquierdo recuerda que hay que
hacer lo mismo el lado derecho que del
lado izquierdo entonces estamos 3x ambos
lados que no resulta del lado izquierdo
tenemos menos 3 x más 9 x es igual a 6 x
menos 18 6 x menos 18 del lado derecho 3
x menos 3 x se cancela y nos queda
simplemente 3 ahora hay varias maneras
de hacer esto pero vamos a seguir el
método tradicional
esto es vamos a sumar 18 a ambos lados
sumamos 18 el lado izquierdo y sumamos
18 del lado derecho que obtenemos del
lado izquierdo 18 con menos 18 se
cancela nos queda solo 6 x estos
términos se cancelaron y del lado
derecho nos queda 3 + 18 es igual a 21
dividimos entre 6 ambos lados 6 en 36 es
1 nos queda x del lado izquierdo y del
lado derecho es 21 sextos simplificamos
21 sextos sacando tercera arriba nos va
a dar siete medios y ya hemos acabado
bien dije que había varias maneras de
hacer esto voy a resolver la ecuación de
otra manera aquí en naranja tenemos 9 x
menos 2 esto es igual a 3 x x + 3
bueno aquí lo que se me ocurre es
dividir entre 3 ambos lados de la
ecuación vamos a dividir entre 3 del
lado izquierdo y del lado derecho hay
que dividir entre 3 ambos suman 2
dividimos entre 3 del lado izquierdo 9
entre tres me queda 3 que multiplica a x
2 y esto es igual 3 x entre 3 es igual a
x + 1 ya podemos distribuir el 3 del
lado izquierdo lo cual nos va a quedar 3
x menos 6 es igual a x + 1 vamos a
agrupar las x del lado izquierdo vamos a
restar x ambos lados del lado izquierdo
de 2 x menos 6 de lado derecho sería
simplemente 1 restamos esta x restamos
esta x para eliminarla ahora sumando 6
ambos lados nos queda el lado izquierdo
2x y del lado derecho queda uno más 67
dividiendo entre 2 obtenemos x es igual
medios fui algo rápido en estos pasos
pero quería mostrarte que mientras los
pasos que sigas sean matemáticamente
válidos vas a obtener siempre
exactamente la misma respuesta y puedes
verificar esta respuesta en la ecuación
original si así lo deseas y ahora
tenemos un problema aplicación veamos si
podemos resolverlo lydia de dos cierta
cantidad de dinero la cual dividió en
cinco partes iguales digamos que m es la
cantidad de dinero que tiene el cual
dividió en cinco partes iguales digamos
que ms entonces el dinero de lidia
dinero de lidia el cual heredó
heredado dinero de lidia heredado el
cual dividió en cinco partes iguales
ella invirtió tres partes del dinero en
una cuenta bancaria de interés alto así
que cuánto invirtió en la cuenta con un
alto interés bancario entonces con un
alto interés
interés bancario cuánto invirtió lidia
lo dividió en cinco partes iguales y de
esas cinco partes iguales 3 las invirtió
a un alto interés bancario entonces su
cantidad de dinero m la dividió en cinco
partes iguales y de esas tres las
invirtió en la cuenta bancaria también
podríamos decir que tres quintos de su
dinero podemos decir entonces que tres
quintos de su dinero lo invirtió una
cuenta con alto interés bancario con la
cual aumentaba 10% de su valor eso fue
lo que invirtió en la cuenta de alto
interés bancaria ella invirtió el resto
de la herencia más 500 dólares en el
mercado de valores y cuánto fue esto
tenemos ahora que en el mercado de
valores hay invirtió el resto de la
herencia así es que si invirtió tres
quintas partes en la cuenta bancaria
cuánto le queda le quedan dos quintas
partes del dinero lo cual va a invertir
en el mercado de valores de acuerdo si
sumas tres quintos y dos quintos tienes
todo el dinero que haya herido pero no
invirtió únicamente eso invirtió el
resto de su dinero dos quintas partes de
m más 500 dólares más 500 dólares en el
mercado de valores pero perdió 20% así
es que esto fue lo que invirtió y
terminó con vamos a poner aquí esto es
lo invertido invertido y terminó con
vamos a ponerlo por acá terminó con así
que en la cuenta bancaria en la cuenta
bancaria aumentó 10 por ciento su valor
así es que empezó con tres quintas
partes de su dinero tres quintas partes
de su dinero y le agregó 10 por ciento
de su valor vamos a ponerlo así 0.10 que
es el 10 por ciento de lo que invirtió
0.10 por tres quintos de m esto es con
lo que termina la cantidad original más
un 10% que se le agregó el 10% que
creció la inversión ahora en el mercado
de valores empezó con esta cantidad con
dos quintos de m más 500 y perdió 20 por
ciento de esa cantidad es decir menos
punto 2 el 20 por ciento
de la cantidad que invirtió de dos
quintos de m más 500 eso es lo que
pierde el 20% de la cantidad que
invirtió y nos dicen si las dos cuentas
terminaron con exactamente la misma
cantidad de dinero cuánto heredó ella
así es que está ahí está terminan siendo
iguales una ecuación para m por resolver
hagamos eso tenemos tres quintos de m
más punto diez por tres quintos punto 10
lo puedo escribir como 1 sobre 10
así es que multiplicando 1 sobre 10 por
tres quintos de m tenemos 3 sobre 50 m
lo único que hice fue multiplicar un
décimo por tres quintos nos da 3 sobre
50 y esto va a ser igual a 2 quintos no
voy a usar el mismo color dejan de usar
el mismo color esto va a ser igual a 2
no sigue saliendo el mismo color salmón
a ver ahora si el mismo color esto va a
ser igual a 2 quintos de m
500 menos punto dos por dos quintos
punto dos es igual a un quinto hagámoslo
por aquí punto dos es igual a 20 sobre
100 y eso es igual a un quinto
sustituimos este punto dos por un quinto
entonces aquí nos queda menos un quinto
que multiplica a dos quintos más pero
dos quintos de m un quinto que
multiplica dos quintos de m más 500 este
es un problema peliagudo pero haciéndolo
poco a poco veremos que no es tan
difícil para empezar tenemos que sumar
tres quintos de algo más 350 voz de alto
tres quintos es lo mismo que treinta
cincuenta vos estoy multiplicando por
diez el numerador y por diez el
denominador y ahora sumamos 30 53 50 vos
eso nos va a dar 33 50 vos
y eso es igual a vamos a simplificar el
lado derecho sería dos quintos de m más
500 y vamos a distribuir este menos un
quinto menos un quinto por dos quintos
es menos 225 abós dm y menos un quinto
por 500 es menos siete simplificamos
esto aún más el lado izquierdo permanece
33 sobre 50m y eso es igual a los
términos nm son dos quintos de m y menos
225 ambos de m lo vamos a poner como dos
quintos menos 225 abós y todo eso
multiplicado por m simplemente
factorizar la semes aquí y acá ya usamos
esos términos y luego tenemos 500 menos
7 eso es más 400 ahora veamos aquí
tenemos dos quintos si multiplicamos el
numerador y el denominador por 5 nos
resulta 10 sobre 25 y la ecuación
resulta ahora 33 sobre 50 m es igual a
10 sobre 25 menos 2 sobre 25 es igual a
8 sobre 25 m más 400 nos estamos
acercando pasemos ahora a la semes del
lado izquierdo de la ecuación restamos
menos 8 sobre 25 m del lado derecho y
también restamos menos 8 sobre 25 m del
lado izquierdo del lado derecho 8 sobre
25 m 8 sobre 25 m se cancelan y nos
quedan simplemente
400 del lado izquierdo tenemos menos 8
sobre 25 m 33 sobre 50 m esto lo podemos
escribir como 33 sobre 50 y menos 8
sobre 25 lo puedo escribir como menos 16
sobre 50 multiplique por dos el
numerador y el denominador y obtuve 16
sobre 50 y eso multiplicado por m va a
ser igual a 400 ya casi llegamos 33
sobre 50 menos 16 sobre 50 33 16 es 16
así es que este término es igual a 17
sobre 50m y esto es igual a 400 vamos a
despejar m multiplicamos por el
recíproco de 17 sobre 50 que es 50 sobre
17 lo hacemos por ambos lados para
mantener la ecuación estos términos se
cancelan y nos queda tan solo m es igual
a 400 por 50 entre 17 saquemos la
calculadora esto va a ser igual a 400
por 50
entre 17 esto nos va a dar igual a
1.176 punto 47 m es igual entonces a
1.176 punto 47 dólares eso fue lo que
recibió lidia de herencia espero que te
has divertido con este vídeo